Hi Michael, how are you doing?
>> Oh, good thanks. What the, what's on tap for today?
>> Well, as you can see on your
screen today we're going to talk about support vector machines.
>> Hmm.
>> And at the end of it, we are going to circle
back to boosting, so that I can try to explain to you
why it doesn't seem to over fit as much as you might
think or at least not in the ways that you make it.
>> Ooh, that would be cool. I was worried that that was maybe a command.
>> What
was a command?
>> The thing that you wrote on the screen.
>> [INAUDIBLE] [LAUGH] Man you know that reminds me of one of my favorite
little thing about police. That any combination
of the word police is a legal sentence
>> [LAUGH] I see.
>> Please.
>> Please. Police Please please. Please police.
>> Please please please please please
please police. Those are all legal sentences.
>> All right, we'll please stop.
>> [LAUGH] Man,
this is why I hang out with you, Michael.
Ok,so today we're going to talk about support vector machines
and I'm going to do something unexpected. I'm going
to start out The beginning of this with a quiz.
>> With a quiz.
>> Yes, with a quiz. So here's the quiz for you, Michael. I've drawn on
here ,uh, some points, some labeled positive
and some labeled minus, representing two different classes.
And, you'll notice that you could draw
a line to separate them, therefore they are
>> Linearly separable.
>> Exactly. So the question I have for you is simply this, which is the
best line? And here's how you're going to show
me. Here's how you're going to show me. I'm
not just going to ask you to draw some random line because that's too hard for
us to get feeback on. So instead what I've done is I've drawn three green dots.
Here on the sort of upper left and three red dots here on the bottom right
and what I want to you to do is select one of the green dots and one
of the red dots and since you'll have
two dots that will define a line and that'll
be the way you indicate to me which of the lines is in fact The best line.
>> The best line.
>> The best line. And I'm not going
to even tell you what best means. You tell
me what best means, when you justify why you would choose one over the other.
>> If I think they're all the best, I can choose any one I want?
>> That's right. Ok. So you got it?
>> I think so.
>> OK. Go.